guillaume depardieu vous nous avez
rejoint donc je suis pas du tout
question d'un droit de réponse puisque
vous n'êtes pas à gérard depardieu vous
êtes guillaume depardieu
mais est ce que votre père vous a
présenté rafik khalifa déjà non non
jamais non donc vous n'avez pas rien de
spécial a déclaré finalement non
monsieur commissaire alors guillaume
depardieu après tous les matins du monde
de cornaux en 91 cible émouvante et les
apprentis de salvadori en 93 95 après
pola x de leos carax en 99
vous êtes à la fiche de peau d'ange le
premier film de vincent pérez avec vous
morgan mort et magali voc karine silla
olivier gourmet laurent terzieff
dominique blanc
valeria bruni tedeschi weeks face le
pitch ouais j'aime bien parce que je
suis pas très doué pour ça alors c'est
simple c'est l'histoire d'un gel qui est
jouée par morgan mort est une curieuse
fille qui vit dans la ferme paternelle
dans un milieu pauvre et défauts on va à
la messe le dimanche matin
et puis ses parents sont tellement
pauvres qu'ils doivent se résigner
envoyer leurs filles travaillé comme
bonne chez des notables de la ville
et là vous débarquez vous guillaume
depardieu vous êtes venu en fait pour
l'enterrement de votre mère mais vous
avez quitté la cérémonie pour boire un
verre parce que ça vaut gonflent voilà
alors vous allez passer la nuit ensemble
pour elles c'est la première fois
qu'elle fait l'amour avec un garçon
c'est un don total elle s'abandonne
complètement alors que pour lui enfin
pau pour vous c'est plutôt une
consolation passagère non
consolation passagers j'irai abandon
nécessaire plutôt c'est à dire qu'après
tout ce que je n'ai pas fait il fallait
que je fasse quelque chose
il fallait que je fasse quelques voiles
à part vous connaissiez peut vincent
perez
mais en fait la personne qui joue dans
le film d'ailleurs et qui a écrit le
scénario karim sylla a été la maîtresse
de votre père gérard depardieu avec qui
elle a eu un enfant et c'est peut-être
pour cela qu'elle a le personnage est
tellement bien écrit vous correspond
tellement bien non non parce qu'elle
n'était pas prévue pour moi au départ
donc alors d'air à l'époque c'est à
l'occasion de la révélation de
l'existence de ce bébé
roxane que vous étiez allait tout casser
dans le hall d'accueil du magazine voici
c'était il ya dix ans oui c'était bien
ça vous souvenez de sa hache c'était
génial
j'ai pris un énorme standard le plus
gros qui avait gelé éclaté sur deux
vigiles un truc qui vaut cher et où il
avait sandrine bonnaire qui avait mis du
purin et du fumier ouais moi voici voilà
dire qu'à l'époque c'était il ya dix ans
il ne sale époque pour vous c'était à la
fin de la même année que vous êtes fait
choper en train de vendre de l'hérault à
la gare de de vaucresson je n'étais pas
en train de vendre c'est des conneries
ça va vraiment gênant je dépannais un
copain parce qu'on était tous dans la
merde ce que ça coûtait moins cher et
rotterdam donc on allait à rotterdam en
chaîne a acheté tout simplement parce
que je voulais pas demandé de l'argent à
qui que ce soit et surtout pas mes
parents ne savaient même pas je me
défoncer nos goûts
[Musique]
d'être tous vantent all way longtemps
oui et alors
balattou quoi en plus dur parce que j'ai
à calmer ou ça vous a rendu plus
agressif ça m'a rendu anti sociale a dit
service
quand tu social gâteau
je sais
un peu plus
antisociales vous dites mon danger c'est
que je n'ai jamais eu peur de grand
chose pas plus de la drogue que de la
prison les excès je connais ouais en
fait j'ai même pas peur de la mort parce
que en fait depuis tout petit ça ma
compagne tout ça c'est des choses qui me
font pas peur
elles vivent avec moi font partie de moi
je sais qu'un jeu ça fait partie de ma
vie je veux dire savait pas c'est une
philosophie
pour nous c'est ma philosophie ouais
j'ai peur de rien déjà 15 ans j'ai eu
des problèmes pour vol avec violence
ouais je suis mon premier séjour en
prison st ça c'était pas bien je ne suis
pas très fier ça c'est pas très fier
ouais c'est pas facile d'être le fils de
depardieu quand même non mais c'est
facile d'être office de personnes
enfin que bon c'est bon je dire j'ai eu
les mêmes difficultés que tout le monde
mais sauf que j'ai un caractère une
nature qui qui font que que ça se voit
ouais vous avez été bien élevés ou pas
très bien parce que votre père dit
souvent qu'à l'époque vous êtes né il
avait 20 ans c'était trois ans avant les
valseuses donc il était encore dans un
petit studio à malakoff
moi je pense que mon père devient
lui-même maintenance atteint mais je
pense qu'il faut vraiment beaucoup de
temps pour faire un homme
il faut après 50 ans c'est long surtout
un garçon c'est vrai vous auriez préféré
être le fils de delon belmondo non non
je suis très content d'être le fils de
mon père malgré tout c'est sous ces tout
fait malgré ce que dit ma mère quoi le
risque peut dire ma mère que bon en plus
ma mère c'est quelqu'un qui
politiquement c'est quand même ce que je
trouve qu'ils se rapprochent le plus de
mon vocabulaire et pour ma façon de
penser mais en même temps j'ai très vite
compris très tôt vers 16 ans que je
ferais jamais fait plus de politique
parce qu'au départ je voulais en faire
je voulais partir faire aller en afrique
mais faire la guérilla quoi c'est à dire
piquer tous les diamants et à rendre
rendre le pognon à ce qui est qui et qui
ils ont quoi c'est à dire le gaz ou le
pétrole les machins mais bon tout le
monde sait enfin j'espère que tout le
monde sait y j'espère que tout le sel
surtout mes jeunes que les hommes
politiques n'ont aucun pouvoir
ouais c'est pas très juste ça pour ça
désolé mon cher noël mais vous n'avez
aucun pouvoir
c'était un peu caricatural vous savez
très bien vous êtes à la merci d'un mot
vous êtes à la merci d'une phrase et
anna merci pas forcément là où les mots
ici en des gardes et lionel jospin
s'était regardé comment je viens
d'esquisser passé la déroute de machin
l'histoire de conseillers vous êtes dans
un tourbillon vous êtes moins de tout
vous êtes finalement ce que je constate
avec monsieur khalifa puisque c'était
sale histoire c'est que j'ai j'ai appris
à fermer ma gueule parce que moi j'ai
j'ai jamais été d'accord vraiment avec
les choix de mon père
là sur beaucoup de choses et politiques
surtout mais considérant que l'argent
domine le monde
si monsieur cahill phares arrivent à me
prouver qu'avec sa stratégie il arrivera
à ce que sa jeunesse ne baigne pas dans
dans ces morts dont vous parlez dans
l'islamisme et puisse rêver de travail
et d'espoir tout simplement rêver là je
veux dire qu importe le discours ni la
méthode pourvu qu'on ait l'ivresse de la
dignité livre la dignité et la visite et
vous savez la dignité
ça peut aller très loin la dignité
ce n'est pas de la dignité du peuple
algérien pitt il s'agit de lui vous
savez là bas ils sont très contents de
khalifa l'un des jeunes
quelques-uns oui s'est défait de masse
et l'effet tapie lui il a réussi là
dinars et où il se trouve
ça marche vous savez l'algérie est un
des pays les plus jeunes du monde
la moyenne d'âge elle est de 23 à 25 ans
ces jeunes là aujourd'hui ils n'ont
aucun espoir
beaucoup d'entre eux d'ailleurs face à
cet ac à cette misère
je veux voir je vais te l'islamisme sur
lequel d'ailleurs joue avec oui mais ça
c'est moi ce que je veux c'est sentir
des passions des jeunes en lui disant
des gens moi quand je veux savoir
quelque chose est sûre il ya une
biographie autorisée de khalifa qui est
absolument extraordinaire que je n'ai
pas amené ici dans laquelle il dit qu'il
fait
coût pour la formation des jeunes
qu'est-ce qu'ils forment il forme des
pilotes d'avion vous croyez que les
jeunes algériens sont nombreux à subir
des formations des pilotes d'avions
'tout ce cataclysme c'est votre père a
des vignobles ya quatre jeunes la
semaine dernière qui sont morts de
botulisme
le botulisme est une maladie liée à la
pauvreté le coup de folie moi j'aime les
deux staphylocoques le seuil en france
d'accord et j'avais dans ma chambre je
risque de perdre ma jambe
j'espère que vous n'avez pas lancer des
cordes ans mais bon me découper en
france il ya des jeux du moment qu'elle
a du pognon regarder du moment qu'il ya
du pognon
est ce qu'on pourrait en employant les
mots et qui c'est qui gouvernent le
monde la sait les états unis d'accord
bon alors à respecter que c'est pas cool
à 58,5 millions s'il ya une bonne
volonté derrière moi je m'en fous moi je
suis pas cynique comme vous donc je dis
je dis que je serai vieux je voulais ça
je ne me résous pas à ce que ce soit les
puissances financières américaines ou
autres qui finance le monde est pour
vous dire sur la frange suis d'accord
avec vous vous avez attrapé une maladie
nosocomiale pour employer un terme
pédant à l'hôpital mais vous savez qu'il
ya quand même des enfants qui vivent
dans les banlieues
peut-être qu'il ya des jeunes du ciment
il ya des enfants qui attrapent des
maladies qui s'appelle le saturnisme
dans des logements insalubres voilà donc
c'est aussi la france est aussi un pays
dans lequel il ya des gens pauvres dans
lequel il ya des gens qui vivent mal et
nous devons nous battre pour qu'ils
vivent mieux c'est ça aussi la nouvelle
afrique j'ai l'âge c'est parce qu'enfin
il monsieur messier ni monsieur ni
monsieur mère qui est aujourd'hui
ministre des finances moi je suis tout
simplement monsieur mamère que vous avez
parlé trop vite c'est tout moi j'aurais
étudier le dossier avant mais on le
connaît bien le dossier qualifieriez
vous le connaissez ménages algériens vue
pour l'instant je vais vous faire
oublier tout ça
et
[Musique]
mozart
le cabinet du requiem ouais la première
fois que guillaume depardieu entendu ce
morceau vous aviez 16 ans c'était un
soir de déprime vous avez mis cette
cassette complètement par hasard vous
avez beau couple aurait ce soir là et
vous avez décidé de changer votre vie et
huit jours après vous avez quitté
l'école voilà l'autre chose qui a changé
votre vie c'est votre fille louise
oui mais plus radicalement ouais parce
qu'au départ j'étais tout seul et puis
j'étais plein de rêves encore mais je me
mets là j'ai en fait ça me change mais
je pourrais même pas l'exprimer parce
que c'est je suis complètement c'est
comme quand on vient de se prendre un
coup à la pointe du menton je suis c'est
chez moi je suis j'admire je peux
qu'admirer ça me ramène à des choses
enfin c'est bouleversante veut du bien
est ce que le fait d'être père
maintenant vous rend plus indulgent
envers votre père oui mais j'avais déjà
fait un peu de travail là dessus quand
même sinon il y aurait eu mort d'homme
guillaume depardieu
bien de pardieu bonsoir alors
faites-vous confiance à l'hôpital nous
allons connaître l'opinion des français
sur ce sujet j'imagine la vôtre oui
malheureusement pas trop confiance c'est
pas ça c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire on je pense vous
reprenez goût à la vie un petit peu
alors la douleur dit vous est parti à 80
%
il me reste des douleurs fantômes mais
c'est quasiment le paradis par rapport à
ce que j'ai vécu presque par un ciment
et le mardi avec une journée - quoi un
peu contrariant à 32 ans ce que vous
avez vécu c'est à dire l'amputation bien
entendu de la moitié de votre jambe
suite à un grave accident de moto en
1995 une valise mal attachées sur le
toit du véhicule qui vous précède
guillaume fractures ouvertes destruction
du genou et 17 opérations
ouais pas prêt jusqu'à une infection due
à un staphylocoque résistant à tout
traitement antibiotique et vous
découvrez qu'il s'agit d'une infection
nosocomiale ce qu'on appelle une maladie
d'hôpital en général vous découvrez
également que plus aucun médicament ne
parvient à atténuer votre souffrance
malgré les dose massive d'antibiotiques
de morphine
le seul résultat finalement c'est de
vous bougiez l'estomac que vous avez
vomi du sang
oui j'ai même attrapé un ulcère enfin
bref tout le tous les à-côtés
souhaitable qu on a évidemment quand on
prend des idées soulevées dose massive
d'antibiotiques
jusqu'à ce que vous trouviez un
chirurgien qui acceptent de deux vous
amputez les autres étaient pas vraiment
d'accord pourquoi ça pose un
un gros problème quand même pas ce que
ça veut dire que c'est presque un plutôt
un constat d'échec
en l'occurrence c'est un constat d'échec
mais en même temps bon j'avais le choix
entre avoir une jambe raide toute ma vie
donc marcher dix ans et puis après avoir
le dos bouvier et puis après avoir une
autre fin de mois on me faire opérer du
col du fémur à 40 ans alors normalement
c'est l'intervention qui vient sauver
les personnes âgées
donc j'ai préféré couper court
aujourd'hui vous militez pour que
d'autres ne subissent pas le même
calvaire car pour vous l'hôpital et
dangereux en fait je suis venu à cette
première démission parce que c'est pour
son titre déjà opinion publique et puis
le fait aussi que yeux des gens informés
sont réunis ici
si guillaume depardieu
[Musique]
voilà
ça se passe mieux que la dernière fois
que tu es venu là pour marché non
j'arrive à escalader un petit peu
commence à prendre l'habitude ouais
alors guillaume depardieu acteur de
cinéma tous les matins du monde cible
émouvante dans les apprentis césar du
meilleur espoir pola x mart peau d'ange
aime ton père donc régulièrement à
l'affiché au cinéma mais aussi souvent
guillaume depardieu à la une des médias
prison ferme pour revendre d'héroïne en
1993 accident de moto en 1995 amputation
de la jambe en 2003 puis altercation à
trouville avec un pistolet à grenaille
neuf mois avec sursis 5000 euros
d'amendé
enfin voilà donc vous êtes un garçon à
la fois qu'on retrouve sur les ailes
d'ange les films et à la une est à la
une des médias et c'est pas fini puisque
vous publié chez plon un livre
d'entretiens réalisés avec marc olivier
fogiel ton ami depuis qu'il est le
dimanche soir c'est plus mon ami quand
l'amitié c'est un jour après et puis
tout va bien tu vas te réconcilier avec
lui et sur ce plateau très volontiers
donc un livre qui va faire grand bruit
et qui s'appelle tout donné
alors guillaume depuis la publication
des bonnes feuilles de ce livre dans
paris match tout le monde en parle c'est
le cas de le dire
et d'ailleurs la première mise en place
chez les libraires a été mercredi
dernier de 80 mille exemplaires alors au
départ c'est muriel bel air qui est
éditeur chez chez plon qui lie un
portrait de vous dans l qui vous appelle
et qui vous dit vous avez une vraie
histoire racontée et vous dites vous
tombez bien j'ai envie d'écrire
donc voilà donc muriel bel air pour
accoucher de ce témoignage
contact marc olivier fogiel avec qu'ils
étaient amis depuis 1997
et donc c'est marco qui vous a accouché
alors au niveau de la méthode de travail
avant de passer au contenu du livre lui
dis tous les jours entre septembre et
décembre 2003 j'étais chez guillaume à
bougival tête bêche sur son lit avec un
magnéto en marche pendant trois heures
par jour non et vous dans le même dans
le même journal vous dites qu'en fait
vous avez enregistré huit entretiens
avec lui c'est quoi alors il ya eu 8
entre un entretien d'une heure en fait
et puis non mais ça ça doit être le
journaliste qui a dû il s'est trompé de
way la vérité c'est ça si vous avez fait
un entretien d'une heure avec lui tête
bêche sur le lit très bien alors on va y
aller un saumon tête bêche
alors le livre commence à votre
naissance vous dites je ne suis pas née
normal ma mère a pris un médicament le
distilbène qui a été ensuite interdit à
cause de ses effets secondaires il 300
cas de jeunes filles qui sont nés
stérile et vous vous avez des
malformations corporelle dites vous des
eaux en plus des trucs comme ça des eaux
plus un cerveau en moi c'est bizarre et
où des eaux en plus d'embrun et on nous
a enlevé ses hôtes n'ont jamais non non
parce que c'était pas sauf si je me
cassais sur l'artère fémorale
non non non ne s'était pas c'est pas
grave et le sexe l'opération du sexe ça
c'est plus marquant quand même se trouve
à la puberté quand ça commence à bien
frétiller 1
déjà tout petit vous vous sentez
différentes voilà c'est ça surtout que
ça paraissait menacé d'avion en classe
appelle moi confiant un succès assez bon
match mais il a passionné quoi il a
vibré
il a vibré ok ça y est on continue t'es
chiant avec 5
donc tout petit déjà vous vous sentez
très différent des autres
ce mouvement marque finalement 7 c ouais
opérations non tu te retrouves à
l'hôpital j'ai eu durant les cours ouais
je dis ce que tu as écouté je vais pas
dire voilà on vous parlait aussi de vos
rapports avec votre père vous dites les
rapports avec mon père sont pas normaux
non plus il travaillait tout le temps je
le voyais jamais il n'était pas
compatissant de ce que vous viviez à
l'école sert qu'à l'école on vous
emmerdez à cause des valseuses à cause
d'un certain nombre de films que votre
père avait fait est en fait jamais il
vous a dit c'est pas grave
laisse tomber guillaume c'est des
connards il t'est pas compatissant non
mais c'est même pas sale d'être
compatissant ou pas c'était je sais pas
moi j'avais pas ne savais pas comment
réagir vite ça donc généralement bon ça
donnait des soucis quand je me battais
tout le temps vous dites mon père il m'a
eu trop tôt on sait que c'est celui qui
dit ce qu'elle veut mais je confirme
gérard depardieu on peut s'il veut pas
trop vous aider parce qu'il n'est pas
beaucoup et à l'école non plus donc oui
c'est assez mais c'est touchant ouais et
alors vers 13-14 ans vous commencez à
put rien [ __ ] ont commencé à fumer du
shit à sniffer de la colle donc c'est
quand même assez jeune ouais vous
trouvez vous dit j'étais devenu
quasiment autistes vrai parce que je
n'ai pas du tout le le monde qui
m'entoure est vrai c'est un peu ennuyeux
au mieux donc me réfugier surtout dans
la musique vous écoutiez quoi de tout
beaucoup de points restent à l'époque
dans le hip hop il est lui vous preniez
le dernier train pour paris vous allez à
paris vous marcher dans les rues pendant
toute la nuit le matin vous preniez le
premier train pour rentrer à bougival
faisait quoi la nuit je déambulais un
peu dans pareil quand j'apprenais je
m'inventais des identités j'avais les
barges été soit fils de notaire soit
fils de
deux militaires soient des trucs
bizarres enfin des trucs comme ça mais
chaque fois j'avais le privilège de
l'anonymat donc c'est comme ça en fait
que je me suis d'abord j'ai compris que
l'on pouvait avec un peu de persuasion
les embobiner tout le monde c'est assez
intéressant et puis ça m'a permis de
découvrir plein d'univers différents
vous disiez jamais que vous étiez le
fils de jarno jamais maintenant sinon
c'est pas drôle
à 16 ans vous décidez comme ça un jour
sur un coup de tête de devenir
mercenaires de partir à mme afrique
larmes au point pour contrôler les
ressources pétrolières et minières et
[ __ ] l'occident dans la merde ça
c'était une grande idée que vous aviez
way
j'étais vraiment prêt à partir mais bien
sûr bien sûr on sait que c'est une
petite barbe de trotskisme
c'est pour le faire la révolution
mondiale non c'est pour ces pour un film
ça c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
vénal ça c'était une semaine où les
autres mercenaires et puis la semaine
d'après vous écoutez le requiem de
mozart vous fondeur l'armée vous dit
c'est ça que je veux être c'est mozart
ouais c'est un peu le résumé comme ça ça
fait un peu mais c'est ça c'est ça
non en fait je voulais vraiment me
barrer pour quelque chose qui valait le
coup est finalement bon j'ai eu la
chance de l'écouter mozart ouais parce
que sinon je me bats et ça vous a retenu
ici
non c'est même une certaine manière
c'est à donner un sens au fait que le
choix ici en occident
je me suis dit mais on peut on peut
arriver aux mêmes choses le but mais en
construisant et pas en détruisant
alors à l'époque vous êtes besoin
d'argent vous n'êtes pas d'argent votre
père non non vous êtes gigolo je sais le
grand court si non non non j'étais c'est
pas pour pas que pour l'argent c'est par
exemple lui première curiosité si bien
sûr vous êtes gigolo pour pour femmes
pour un homme
vous commencez avec des femmes mûres
j'aimais bien les fameux mur est donc là
c'était pas tellement pénible non non
c'était plutôt oui c'est bien ce que si
c'était gigolo de luxe quoi vraiment
j'avais le choix chez les clients ouais
ouais c'est toujours plus agréable avec
des mecs aussi vous raconter le premier
mec
le premier ouais 14 ans ouais mais s'est
pas passé grand-chose la première fois
heureusement non juste préliminaire
ouais et après c'était plus sérieux
c'est arrivé ouais vous avez appris quoi
dans cette expérience
benjamin tournelle d'autres signifier
des douches
non non j'ai appris mais j'ai appris
plein de choses j'ai appris que c'était
dans la tête aussi les choses s'étaient
ralliés heureusement quand vous vous
retrouvez en tour de la première fois il
ya un caïd qui vous protège et vous
échapper aux sévices sexuels habituel
des prisons ou enfin aux sévices sexuels
non je pense pas que que j'étais une
proie
ainsi niveau là non j'ai échappé surtout
lynchage
ouais pendant la première phase aller en
taule c'est pas encore pour usage de
stupéfiants ce pour braquage de weston
et de rester l'époque la grande de jun
mais ça va encore ouais enfin bon
et puis quand est ce qu'on met des
personnes avec une doudoune je les
passais fond du gouffre
oui là on est dans les piverts 18 ans
vous commencé à mettre le nez dans la
poudre
c'est la durée six ans 8 j'ai perdu six
ans de ma vie là dedans
ouais mais je pense que nous a rien
apporté du tout si mais ça m'a apporté
justement de mais rétrospectivement
parce que je m'en suis sorti mais parce
que je suis costaud quand même non mais
moi j'en connais tous mes potes de
l'époque sont s'en sont pas sortis ils
sont soit devenu fou soit ils sont morts
soit ils ont fait aujourd'hui je me sens
bien là en fait le mec qui vous a
branché dans la drogue dans la poudre
dans l'héroïne c'est votre prof de
solfège
ouais de contrepoint d'harmonie vous
recueillez un jour chez vous parce que
son père était mort et un jour vous le
voyez en train de se faire un fixe dans
la salle de bain et vous essayez quoi
ouais enfin j'avais ici un petit peu
avant je faisais un remplacement
je vais avoir 16 ans quand j'ai essayé
mais c'était juste un trait d'héroïne
ont un hasard quand même ça m'a rien
fait alors là évidemment quand on prend
de l'héroïne au début c'est vachement
bien on croit que tous les problèmes
sont réglés même c'est après comme on
dit toujours au début on en prend pour
être bien puis après peut pas être
humain lui tenait donc après on court
après alors vous essayez tout voir vous
ici non seulement l'héroïne mais aussi
l'héroïne mélangé à de la cocaïne ce
qu'on appelle le speedball le speedball
ensuite vous avez pris du crack vous
ayez pas peur de vomi quel cerveau non
non mais j'ai lu quelque part qu'on
utilisait on utilisait toute façon juste
un dixième de nos neurones ont toute une
existence fois - et donc mon nom mais
j'avais pas une approche très
quantitative des choses c'était plutôt
c'est plutôt fallait tout essayer
ouais et puis un jour en revenant de
hollande ou par départir pour le ski
quand le fameux prof de solfège qui vous
a initiés vous appelle il vous dit je
suis mal je suis mal viennent des panais
mais j'étais parti pour décrocher un don
qui vous appelle je suis mal bien viens
viens
bien mais des flammes avaient pas les
choses deviennent dépanner c'était un
truc bon je comptais pour pas être
prendre pour peut-être mal le prendre le
lendemain matin
ouais et pourront j'ai vu passer et puis
là j'ai vu le flag est vraiment comme ça
je descends en plus vous faites serré
vous finissez donc évidemment en prison
alors en prison vous dites kapaya pas de
broc évidemment ya pas d'héroïne mais il
ya la fiole c'est quoi la fiole mais
c'est ce qu'on donne en tout dans toutes
les prisons en france c'est une donne à
ça pour les mecs parce qu'ils sont il ya
beaucoup de toxico quand même les vols
avec violences ou les vols quels qu'ils
soient enfin la rapine tout ça c'est
vraiment l'essentiel des gens qui en
prison à 70 % c'est lié au manque et à
la drogue
donc on leur donne pour les calmer pour
pas qu'ils hurlent toute la nuit comme
en ce moment qu'on leur donne des
tranquillisants des opiacés des enfants
les shoots quoi on va et prévôt oui mais
un jour ouais un jour ou deux puis après
toute façon moi j'étais barré quand même
que je voulais m'arrêter là ça tombait
bien aller certaine façon un jeu vous
prévenir votre rappel balladur pour
essayer de vous faire sortir de là en
fait vous lui en voulez parce qu'il
trouvait que ces quand même trop facile
d'être le fils de gérard depardieu non
mais c'est moi je sais pas du tout comme
ça j'ai jamais été comme ça et je serai
jamais comme ça non j'ai été condamné
j'estime injustement
ils en voulaient c'est un exemple de
croix c'était le changement de politique
tu vois c'était un peu la droite qui y
vivent mais il fallait bien montrer que
attention maintenant les jeunes ça
rigole plus on est donc bien là
maintenant continuer à dérouler même
tapis quoi donc c'est assez intéressant
de voir que ça ne sert strictement à
rien et qui met pas les gens qui sont
malades en prison sur sa ridicule
vous avez voulu à votre père d'avoir
essayé d'intervenir auprès de nouvelles
à bazire est pas la dire vous auriez
préféré finalement qu'il voulait cela
pour un plancher a préféré que qu'ils
soient pas là du tout qui viennent pas
en plus me discréditer
moi j'ai dire je voulais faire ma peine
jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas de problème
là dessus je viens
moi je fais ma peine c'est le même si
j'estime que j'ai rien à [ __ ]
là-dedans justement c'est motivant c'est
très motivant et je vous vouliez vous
c'était une certaine rédemption par là
par la punition non pas du tout normales
à dieu m'en garde nous avoir ce genre de
pensée la gelée aux chrétiens et non
merci non non non c'est plutôt devoir de
mettre les choses à plat avec l'esprit
clair et de voir dans quelle société
j'évolue et donc à partir de là c'est
très bien je sais que je suis malade je
sais maintenant que on prend les
manettes comme ça qu'on en fait ça je
sais avoir les idées claires et arrêté
six ans plus tard vous et arrêtez
comment tout seul sans rien non sans
méthadone comme ça ouais solide dure
voilà et puis ensuite vous raconter dans
le bouquin votre amputation suite à
cette maladie nosocomiale
on vous propose soit d'avoir la jambe
raide toute votre vie soit vous faire
amputer ça fait un bon petit parallèle
devant les mecs qui sont malades dont
les fonds ont tous les mecs qui vont les
autres exemples ouais j'ai testé pour
vous ouais vous avez préféré être amputé
plutôt que voilà j'aimerais ça faisait
un peu intenable et en faisant pouvait
plus rien faire
non mais il y en a même qui m'ont dit
quand même attitude y aller vers l'est
pas fait comme tout le monde mais il y
en a qui arrivent à dire ça les yeux
dans les yeux en pensant vraiment que
c'est vrai que j'ai fait exprès pour
faire bien dans le curriculum alors
votre père vous appelle donc après cette
amputation et vous appelle à l'hôpital
il vous dit ça va comment vous dites ça
va très bien espèce de sarcasmes ça va
très bien j'ai fait un drôle de rêve
papa j'étais entouré de flea toute nue
qui me sucer le moignon moi j'ai vu tous
il est vraiment il avait des limites au
sens de l'humour nous dit mon père je
l'aimais je le déteste pour les mêmes
raisons son impuissance
non mais c'est toujours pareil de façon
les gens les aiment
quand on les aime vraiment si vous les
avez aussi pour leurs défauts il n'a pas
été assez dur avec vous pensez
franchement ouais non jeu non mais c'est
une manière autrement plus dur aussi de
vous dire à quelqu'un me démerde toi tu
vas voir à la dure moi je trouve que ça
m'a amené vers une liberté qui est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai ça je dois le
concéder je trouve que c'est intéressant
de dire à quelqu'un démerde toi toute
façon tu vas être bien être obligé de te
démerder donc mais ce qui est peut-être
un peu tôt est-ce que vous lui en voulez
de ne pas vous avoir donné un exemple
parce que vous dites dans le bouquin mon
père s'est fait ce que je dis ne faites
pas ce que je fais ouais vous trouvez
qu'il manque d'intégrité et d'éthique
c'est à dire que vous pensez que
finalement dire que non non mais quand
on quand on a des trucs soit faut le
cacher vraiment quoi il faut pas que ça
se voit sur les ferries qui soient plus
discrets pour vous donner un exemple
plus plus droit bah oui je suis pas ton
café après ne pas venir en se posant en
représentante en garant de la justice
quelle qu'elle soit
après mois après ce que j'ai vu tu vois
un succès c'est pas le top crédibilité
quoi ouais j'avoue découvrez ben oui
comme tous les gens de sa génération
vous découvrez kiseka mais qu'il avait
par tous voila quoi comme moi non mais
ça c'est bien après ouais moi j'étais
déjà barré depuis longtemps j'étais déjà
ma tête c'était vous avez dix ans
j'étais déjà dans mon univers ne l'est
plus m'approcher quoi du coup là même
qu'il a une fille avec karine silla
bonisseur il n'a pas osé vous en parlez
vous la prenez la prison de sa naissance
parce que karine silla appelez votre
père devant vous ouais pour dire que
tout s'était bien passé nous apprenait
sa vie privée par la presse en fait
ouais mais aujourd'hui aussi la manière
dont vous l'avez appris en disant par
ailleurs ajouté un peu a franchi vin
parce que maintenant je sais voir un peu
les rapports
ouais je trouve ça bien moi je trouve ça
bien qu'ils soient avec cette femme là
ouais ouais
préférez les fagnes ardeur à carole
bouquet j'ai rien dit alors parler de
votre mère aussi lisabeth depardieu vous
dites qu'ils sont en instance de divorce
depuis 14 ans parce qu'il veut pas
lâcher sur le plan polluants
oui monsieur lamy les milliardaires
votre permis franchement c'est assez
opaque un ouais je vois pas ce que vous
dites quand j'étais petit me donnez pas
d'argent
ma mère il veut pas divorcer parce qu'il
veut pas lâcher non mais qu'on justice
car si fier c'est beaucoup d'argent
principes d'éducation ma main et je
trouve ça très bien d'ailleurs
c'est à dire que moi je n'avais pas plus
d'argent que mon meilleur ami est bon
comme c'est une famille nombreuse quatre
enfants des milieux bon impôt 1
donc moi j'ai trouvé ça très bien mais
non mais mon père il n'est pas du tout
pas généreux c'est pas vrai il faut pas
qu'on croit ça non plus et c'est
quelqu'un qui a du mal à filer une pièce
par contre peu de feeling brics ouais
bon moi j'ai pas j'ai pas tendance à
demander facilement une brique vous
avait divorcé c'était réglé à laquelle
il n'avait pas attendu 14 ans quoi ouais
on est on est on est en train de faire
oui heureusement que les louise quand
même non oui alors quand votre père a lu
le bouquin il nous a dit que certains
passages étaient pas bien qu'ils étaient
un an mais parce qu'il n'avait pas lu
il connaît comment ils disent c'est
comme quand il dit je lis les scénarios
il avait fêté trois trucs
si vous un dialogue intéressant et le
prend s'il voit un truc et après le lit
mais bon là il avait juste parcouru
trois feuillets il a dit oui en france
stigmatisent juste pour me dire qu'il
trouvait ça un pudique
ouais et vous lui avez dit que vous le
trouviez indécent ouais il la lui
maintenant je pense vous est pas une
nouvelle non il vous répondra en en gala
vous l'avez lu ah bah oui j'ai eu des
nouvelles par exemple c'est terrible ce
qu'il dit parce que en fait il dit si ça
l'aide décrire ce bouquin tant mieux
pour lui si elle vous attendez comme
attitude vous voyez attendront violent
franchement je m'en fous ça me m'empêche
pas de dormir c'est pas ça qui me fait
lever le matin
ouais maintenant vous avez fait ce
bouquin vous sentez libéré de quelque
chose - je sens en tout cas on ne posera
plus les mêmes questions à chaque fois
que j aimerais faire la promo pour un
truc que j'ai fait que j'estime très
bien et qui mérite plus largement de la
tension plutôt que sur ma famille ou
quoi que ce soit comme ça j'ai fait
aussi pour ça que j'ai trouvé bien mon
intérêt là dedans comme face au coucher
avec ma famille laguë dans les ronces et
je trouve c'est infernal c'est terrible
ça va les gens vont se lasser attention
gérard sa dernière fois vous en parler
là alors oui c'est à dire j'aime bien
marquer le coup quand même la dernière
fois c'est énorme ce groupe après vous
avez paraître vos films oui je vais les
faire sur tout alors guillaume vous avez
vidéo vous avez eu des barbes faire
l'interview à peine dame
[Musique]
ce que vous préférez chez vous la
qualité de mes silences ce que vous
haïssez chez vous la qualité de mes
silences au cinéma ce que vous préférez
au cinéma les gens et rencontres ce que
vous haïssez au cinéma est con way
le plus grand moment de votre vie ouais
jeu original la naissance de ma fille le
pierre le pire la naissance de tempère
je sais pas encore non ce qui vous plaît
le plus dans la vie après l'amour
ce qui me plaît le moins attendre avant
votre plus gros coup de fric c'est un
truc que j'ai pas fait justement c'est
mais c'était pour faire monter les
enchères pour voir jusqu'où ils
pouvaient aller le plus grosse perte
bah c'est ça s'il n'a pas fait un peu
plus belles histoires d'amour guillaume
laurent mbassi ya un soufflage ma plus
belle histoire d'amour sert un ma fille
est la plus minable la plus minable
le jour où j'ai failli tomber à moins de
noirs ouais qu'est celui de plus sexy en
vous je sais pas et de moins sexy quand
je suis bourré ouais ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe moi j'aime tout
tout ce que vous détestez le sexe les
interdits et qui a aussi deux duos sur
cet album il y en a avec françois morel
qui s'appelle mémère dans les orties il
vous insulter copieusement en automne
certains se donnent des noms d'oiseaux
nous c'est des noms de poissons ça y va
ah ouais la morue le maquereau enfin
tout y passe à la fin il nous traite
comme de liposucer quoi ouais mais on
l'a on en fait on a fondé la marge est
sûre et puisqu'on avait une coda de
chansons que tu es plus longue la
chanson donc on est on est parti dans la
proue et c'était terrible hein et bien
un duo avec avec guillaume depardieu une
chanson magnifique qui s'appelle une
lettre oubliée alors en deux mots c'est
un jeune homme qui écrit une lettre à sa
bien aimée ça commence comme ça par une
lettre sa bien aimée et puis très
rapidement on entend une voix de femme
qui est finalement en train de relire
cette lettre des années plus tard et qui
se souvient absolument pas qui est ce
qui a pu lui envoyer ça et c'est une
lettre poignante d'autant plus qu'en
avançant dans la chanson on s'aperçoit
que le garçon est en train de l'écrire
il est au front on l'appelle il est 5
heures et il va falloir y aller on sait
pas ce qui va devenir en tout cas
il lui demande en conclusion de ne cite
jamais il lui arrivait quelque chose de
ne jamais l'oublier
voilà raté quoi
[Musique]
je le voulais
et qui ma foi
l'art
voyez
tu sais de quel ennui
leur ordre je savoure
et c'est andré
où elle s'enraye
c'est sympa
si aux yeux rires me disent très
fouillis
kiddo
un peu
et tout mon coeur est pris
sur le droit
peut-être lui
[Musique]
on
un choix
je reviendrai se revend sur rennes
je vois
et qui
très posé
[Musique]
il va sûrement
ceux de l'être
tél
pour situer
[Musique]
fr
ubilla
ces heures séjour
six secondes
c'est harry
je vais vous chercher dans l'eau
de mes hommes
c
tant que l'homme
si au fond
cet amour
c.noyer moi c'est très bonnes chansons
ça donne
et alors c'est extraordinaire c'est que
vous racontez au camp guillaume et est
venu pour interpréter sa partie du duo
dans le studio tout le monde avait les
larmes aux yeux c'était c'est un moment
super émouvant lui s'en est pas rendu
compte il dans la cabine
une prise était oui c'est en fait y en a
on en a fait 3 on a gardé la deuxième
puisque la première était très tendue et
puis il y avait évidemment la découverte
de la de la musique de la chanson ce
genre un peu il faut se mettre dedans
croire et on a gardé la deuxième qui
était absolument magnifique tout en
émotion en fait et puis c'est vrai que
quand sako chose qu'il a commencé dans
le studio
on était tous bon moi je me regardais
plus je sais pourquoi je donnais pas les
déports et c'était la rue complet on
était tous conscience regarder plus on
était l'ingénieur du son il était payé
la tête rentrée dans les épaules et en
été en étant une émotion folle encore
très émouvant que c'est la première fois
guillaume que tu que tu chantes comme ça
c'est beau hein
seydoux et non c'est vrai vous dites
c'est un ange
c'est comme ça qu'ils sont les anges
ouais c'est les noms je fais les fêlés
alors c'est vrai bon ben voilà donc
voilà on vous fait des duos vous et des
passages radio de la pub télé quand vous
n'êtes pas du tout en bis bis contre
votre maison de disque fait jamais rien
comme les autres donc en fait ma maison
disent que je les adore vous êtes prête
à jouer le jeu donc c'est pas jouer le
jeu c'est eux qui joue mon jeu retraites
c'est moi
finalement c'est ça l'idée c'est que
j'écris des chansons et puis elle salle
aura bien plus sains déjà les maquettes
et puis voilà quoi après je suis arrivé
avec des idées en dix ans j'aimerais
bien voila j'aimerais bien faire un duo
hardy view
guillaume tu penses à quoi lancement à
l'homosexualité féminine ou masculine et
de l'es2 viala je me sens totalement bin
ouais ouais t'as c'est beau comme mec
l'a pas inventé la poudre
on vas tu fais quoi quand tu te regarde
dans la glace le matin je crois en dieu
mais dans le mauvais sens ta plus belle
histoire d'amour c'est là qu'elle non
c'est bien ouais ça va c'est quand la
dernière fois que tu as pleuré rien
pourquoi nous écouter une chanson
ouais tu changerais quoi en tout
installer une baguette magique tout pas
la tête là s'il allait bien trouve pas
qu'il est beau cynthia et charmant
qu'est ce tu pourrais dire de plus
négatif sur toi je suis égoïste
tu ferais quoi site rester 24 heures à
vivre pour un crédit crédit
tout
elle déjà pensé au suicide oui et alors
bois tu l'a pas fait mais je défais mais
ça va marcher tous pareils qu'est ce que
la vita a pris jusqu'à maintenant rien
rien comment aimerais tu mourir vite tu
as menti l'accueil que tu me réponds non
[Musique]
il a fait tirer une carte son
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi vous devez les allongée et
parler de votre en france
et ben voilà bah écoute ouais là sur la
scène sécuritaire des attentes et des
tabourets sont relatés chaque fameux
alors occupée de pièces tu veux bon
allez parle nous de ton enfance il y est
allé
[Applaudissements]
en fait je suis un cas d'école mes
parents mes parents et c'est beaucoup
il était il était vachement gentil avec
moi et il me laissait faire exactement
ce que je voulais mais en même temps ils
m'ont appris des notions essentielles
comme le bien le mal l'honnêteté
l'obéissance la tolérance le respect
choses comme ça donc c'est assez gavant
parlez moi de votre réveil à la
sexualité
mon éveil à sexualité a dû se faire un
âge relativement normal j'ai ouvert 13
ans quoi 12 13 ans comment ça s'est
passé comment ça s'est passé je pense
que c'est passé comme beaucoup de gens
par l'espèce de rêveries romantiques
autour de personnages de romans moi je
suis tombé dans les malheurs de sophie
les trucs comme ça c'est de la config
est parce que c'est l'état zhou wei
souhaité et tous étaient vachement bien
j'adorais ça et puis et les poissons
qu'on découpe les poissons oui j'ai
détruit super cruel semblant et tout ça
j'adorais ça donc je pense que ça j'ai
sanglant à l'époque
voilà ça commençait bien
c'est pas moi qui les ventriloques est
ce que tu veux qu'on fasse rire et une
cata à guillaume habillerait docteur oui
merci je n'ai pas beau
certainement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dommage
mais quoi j'aurais pu le faire c'est la
lutte finale
robben ou et demain lara turn à cela
la lucha finale 'nos groupe amossy par
ailleurs la mer
bon lucian mais ça pata pata
j'accueille jeanne moreau julie
depardieu guillaume debart
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
le voici jeanne moreau bonsoir jamais ni
de bar du bon soir qu' on ne part du
grand soir vous êtes ici tous les trois
pour les rois maudits la grande fiction
de prestige que france 2 diffusera à
partir du 7 novembre
alors au départ les rois maudits c-17
volume écrit par maurice druon en 1955
adapter une première fois à la
télévision par claude barma
le papa de catherine voilà ça a été un
des grands événements de la rtf c'est
vraiment un feuilleton culte de la
télévision ce qui n'a pas empêché josée
dayan de s'y recoller avec anne-marie
qu'à toi pour le scénario est la peur de
rien jose and the dap le truc le plus
énorme de lower tf
elle leur fait un courageuse n'ont
toujours très courageuse prenantes josé
sinon c'est une vraie feuilletoniste
quoi au sens noble du terme à la faye
monte cristo elle a fait les misérables
a fait balzac est là un souffle comme ça
là à la dumas
un peu comme les grands feuilletonistes
du 19e siècle et puis elle s'est
fabriqué à fabriquer ouais elle va vite
un way commencé pour les acteurs c'est
emballant
bon alors l'histoire des rois maudits
c'est la malédiction qui pèse sur fip
lebel et ses successeurs
car tu connais l'histoire laurence hier
qu'il allait brûler vif jacques de molay
le grand maître de l'ordre des templiers
parce qu'ils avaient trop de pouvoir et
le type lui dit maudit soyez tous maudit
pendant treize générations alors mais
c'est aussi le combat que se livrent
mahaut d'artois incarné par jeanne
moreau et robert d'artois incarné par
philippe torreton pour la possession du
comté d'artois voilà mais là aussi elle
a deux filles dont une galana dont une
julie vous êtes jeunes de poitiers vous
êtes la fille de mao avait épousé fils
de poitiers qui est le fils du roi
philippe le bel voilà c'est important
d'avoir un roi comme genre voilà et
l'autre fils du roi c'est vous guide
louis 10 le utah c'est ce que ça veut
dire le hutin maintenant le désagréable
le fantasque n'a pas vraiment ce qui est
très agréable dans cette série c'est
qu'il ya un mélange d'acteurs incroyable
il ya des gens de l'ancienne génération
on retrouve jean claude drouot qui
faisait thierry la fronde alors en plus
il a il est chauve il a une tête mais on
dirait que tu veux ma recette avec jean
claude dos il ya daniel emile fort qu si
tu te souviens tu connais très bien
grand acteur l'astral hague ouais il
fait un choix que j'avais le maître
martin il est vraiment inquiétant il ya
jean claude brialy claude rich
cki cariou jeanne moreau voilà et puis
aussi vous 2 julie et guillaume ix et
julie gayet il ya hélène fillières il ya
un mélange de plusieurs générations
d'acteurs qui se retrouvent là et
finalement ça se passe
ça se passe très bien quoi franchement
vachement bien voilà alors qui est
extraordinaire c'est que cette saga à un
peu shakespearienne elle est traitée
comme un space opera on est dans une
espèce de moyenâgeux futuriste avec des
décors de philippe druillet qui a fondé
métal hurlant et c'est vrai que c'est
drôle voilà c'est extraordinaire d'avoir
fait appel à lui c'est une super idée
les costumes de mini lampe ica et puis
beaucoup d'effets spéciaux de trucages
numériques ce qui fait que ça se regarde
très bien à quoi tu joues c'est pas du
tout je vous dise pas du tout une série
historique chiens non pas du tout non
alors tout est très dessiné un par
exemple vous vous avez la mèche blanche
et puis toujours une robe violette
intendant pendant tout le film quoi
voilà
et puis torreton lullaby en rouge son
cheval était bien en rouge enfin c'est
très bon de dessiner en même temps c'est
vrai que c'est très facile d'accès voilà
alors on va je vais m'arrêter rassurez
vous on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
je vais regarder tous les trois votre
caméra et vous allez dire en même temps
sinon ça marchera pas
tu es trop attention vous aider en même
temps magnéto serge khalfon je sais
c'est compliqué mais faut savoir
qu'après non c'est une passion 2
t'attendais à quoi je peu près
laurent sur toi un peu après ces moments
là je le sens m'a dit si tu prends
surtout alors attention attention
assange de sens elle dit j'étais en
train de te parler
allez-y bon allez attention à 3 a
toujours un mais vous le ratez pas non
plus dire en même temps il est sauf si
le plus tôt dans l'émission sur un deux
trois allait-on serge pas mal
[Musique]